this is the complete history of
artificial intelligence illustrated
entirely by artificial intelligence
thousands of years ago greek myths told
of giant automatons talos was a bronze
giant designed to defend the island of
crete he would throw boulders at the
ships of invaders and slowly circle the
island every day the myth says that
hephaestus forged talos as a gift to the
son of zeus the ancient egyptians also
believed in artificial intelligence and
built sacred mechanical statues that
were said to be capable of wisdom and
emotion and many other civilizations
built realistic humanoid automatons in
an attempt to reproduce the true nature
of humanity in a mechanized form
throughout the 17th and 18th centuries
many philosophers reasoned that the
process of human thought could be
mechanized thomas hobbs and rene
descartes explored the possibility that
all rational thought could be
systematized as simple algebra even
though simple calculating machines had
existed for centuries it wasn't until
the early 19th century that charles
babbage and ada lovelace designed a
truly programmable computer it was
called the analytical engine and
although it was never built it remains a
remarkable turning point in the
development of computer science the
theoretical underpinnings of modern
computing progressed steadily with
george boole inventing boolean algebra
in 1854 and then bertrand russell and
alfred whitehead describing formal logic
in 1913. the first half of the 20th
century led to an explosion of science
fiction depicting artificially
intelligent robots the wizard of oz
featured a tin man who lacked a heart
but otherwise operated like any other
human being and in 1927 a german science
fiction film named metropolis depicted a
machine person who poses as a woman by
the 1950s proper work on artificial
intelligence was starting to take shape
the english mathematician alan turing
suggested that humans use available
information as well as reason in order
to solve problems and make decisions so
why couldn't a machine do the same thing
turing was born in 1911 and by all
accounts was a mathematical savant upon
graduating from college he published a
paper titled on computable numbers in
which he described what would later be
known as a touring machine this paper
built on ideas proposed by kurt godel
and outlined a machine that would be
capable of solving any computable
function today we use the term turing
complete to describe fully functional
real-world general-purpose computers or
programming languages essentially this
new turing machine would not be
specialized but instead could solve any
computing problem during world war ii
touring focused on practical
applications of mathematics and computer
science he used cryptography to break
axis ciphers and decode military
communications this code breaking work
was highly specialized and didn't
utilize a turing machine but it
demonstrated the incredible abilities of
the nascent computer science field after
the war touring began working on
artificial intelligence but there were
some big obstacles in his way first
computers needed to fundamentally change
before 1949 computers were unable to
store commands they could only execute
them basically computers could be given
instructions but they couldn't remember
what they did second computing was
extremely expensive at the time leasing
a computer for a single month would cost
upwards of two hundred thousand dollars
only large technology companies and
prestigious universities could afford to
experiment with computers but this was
about to change artificial intelligence
researchers needed to get some attention
they needed high profile people to
endorse new initiatives and they needed
reliable sources of funding fortunately
the field of artificial intelligence was
about to get a lot more interesting in
1950 alan turing was the deputy director
of the computing laboratory at the
university of manchester while there he
published a paper in a philosophical
journal called mind with a simple idea
called the imitation game turing asked
if a computer could imitate the sentient
behavior of a human would that not imply
that the computer itself was sentient
essentially if a human tester could no
longer tell the difference between human
and computer interactions then the
computer would pass the test and we
would have to admit that computers
possessed human level intelligence
building a machine that could pass this
so-called touring test wouldn't be easy
though the computer would have to
process natural language be able to
learn from a conversation and remember
what had been said then it would need to
communicate ideas back to the human and
understand common sense that same year
isaac asimov published his three laws of
robotics the first law a robot may never
injure a human being or through inaction
allow a human being to come to harm the
second law a robot must obey the orders
given it by human beings except where
such orders would conflict with the
first law the third law a robot must
protect its own existence as long as
such protection does not conflict with
the first or second laws asimov explored
the implications of these three laws in
a variety of science fiction stories and
wound up educating the public about
machine intelligence and illustrating
some of the complex paradoxes inherent
in attempts to control robots with
interest in ai growing steadily things
were about to hit a turning point in
1956 dartmouth college held the summer
ai conference a group of scientists had
created an ai proof of concept called
the logic theorist the program was
designed to mimic the problem-solving
skills of a human and is often called
the first ai program in history the
dartmouth conference was hosted by john
mccarthy and marvin minsky and had a
clear goal show the world that ai was
the future the conference brought
together top researchers from various
fields and actually marked the first
usage of the term artificial
intelligence the event fell short of
expectations though with most people
leaving without strong alignment around
standard methods in the field despite
this minor setback everyone now believed
that building ai was achievable and that
set off a 20-year boom in the field the
50s and 60s led to remarkable progress
in ai research computers were getting
faster cheaper and more accessible
machine learning algorithms were
improving rapidly and most importantly
people got better at knowing which
algorithm to apply to specific problems
many early ai programs used an algorithm
called reasoning as search the idea was
to have the program proceed toward a
goal step by step as though it were
trying different routes in a giant maze
the problem was that for many problems
the number of possible paths through
this maze was simply astronomical a
situation known as combinatorial
explosion researchers would reduce the
search space by using heuristics or
rules of thumb to avoid unlikely paths
but this brute force approach still had
many drawbacks nevertheless advances in
so-called symbolic ai led to a number of
key projects it was during this time
that carnegie mellon researchers
developed the general problem solver and
john mccarthy and marvin minsky created
the mit ai lab the first chat bot was
developed at mit in 1965 the program was
called eliza and would carry on a
conversation in english on any topic
general motors also began using an
industrial robot called unimate on their
automobile assembly line these successes
convinced the us government to fund more
ai research at leading institutions
darpa was particularly interested in
developing a machine that could
transcribe and translate spoken language
something that ai is extremely good at
today but was still in its infancy back
in the 60s everyone was optimistic about
the coming age of artificial
intelligence and that led to aggressive
predictions about the future in 1970
marvin minsky told life magazine that we
will have a machine with the general
intelligence of an average human being
in three to eight years the basic
framework now existed for developing ai
systems but a host of new problems were
about to emerge breaking through the
initial fog surrounding the fundamental
concepts of ai revealed a vast mountain
of obstacles the biggest challenge was
the lack of computing power at the time
computers simply couldn't store enough
information or process it fast enough to
do anything meaningful human
communication requires knowing not only
the meanings of a huge dictionary of
words but also how to understand them in
many combinations a doctoral student of
john mccarthy named hans moravec
articulated the problem well when he
said computers were still millions of
times too weak to exhibit intelligence
as progress stalled so did the funding
streams the well of government money
that had been fueling innovation dried
up and research stagnated for a decade
it was the first ai winter and it would
shape the way researchers thought about
making predictions for decades to come
part of the problem was that ai research
was largely undirected at the time
researchers would try lots of different
ideas with no clear application in mind
but the mansfield amendment of 1969 put
pressure on darpa to fund
mission-oriented directed research as a
result darpa shifted to funding projects
with clear objectives like autonomous
tanks and battle management systems the
permafrost left by the ai winter would
finally thaw during the 1980s a new
methodology called expert systems
promised to be more directly applicable
to real-world problems so corporations
began funding new research expert
systems were designed to directly mimic
the decision-making processes of humans
the idea was to collect information from
experts on how to respond to all sorts
of situations and once a reasonable
answer has been collected for virtually
every situation anyone could use the
system to receive advice the japanese
government poured hundreds of millions
of dollars into these expert systems as
part of their fifth generation computer
project but unfortunately most of the
ambitious goals fell short of
expectations despite this particular
approach failing to launch the increased
funding did inspire an entire generation
of young engineers and scientists to
pursue artificial intelligence research
and although expert systems would prove
to largely be a dead end in another
corner of the research world a new
method called deep learning was starting
to take hold in 1982 the physicist john
hopfield was able to prove that a neural
network could learn and process
information in a completely new way
around the same time jeffrey hinton and
david rummelhart popularized a method
for training neural networks called back
propagation these neural networks would
be commercially successful in the 1990s
when they began to be used as the
engines driving programs like optical
character recognition and speech
recognition even though ai researchers
were finally making headway and about to
reach the top of the mountain another ai
winter set in many of the ambitious
goals had once again fallen short of
expectations like the ability for a
machine to carry on a casual
conversation so governments began
slowing the funding pipeline to a drip
the ai winter that lasted from 1987 to
1993 was different from the previous
winter though this time ai thrived
despite tight budgets the public had
stopped paying attention and robotics
were no longer on the cover of every
newspaper but leading ai researchers
kept working in 1997 artificial
intelligence was back in the limelight
after a chess playing computer program
named deep blue defeated the world chess
champion and grand master gary kasparov
the match was highly publicized and
marked the first time in history that a
reigning world chess champion had been
beaten by ai in the same year speech
recognition software hit the mainstream
with the release of dragon naturally
speaking for windows it was now clear
that ai could not only play games but
could also speed up everyday life ai
research expanded to new areas around
the turn of the millennium interactive
robot pets became commercially available
mit researchers created a robot with a
face that could express emotions and
irobot launched an obstacle avoiding
autonomous vacuum many of these systems
were still incredibly limited but
advances in deep learning and big data
were about to change all of that the
21st century brought about exponential
growth in both computing power and data
storage
neural networks had proven capable of
incredible results but they needed to be
trained on massive data sets using the
most powerful computers in the world in
2004 darpa launched the grand challenge
and offered prize money for any team
that could produce a functional
autonomous vehicle this kicked off a
heated race to develop a fully
self-driving car that still rages on to
this day sebastian throne led the
development of a robotic vehicle named
stanley that won the 2005 darpa grand
challenge he then joined google to lead
their self-driving car project nasa also
began using autonomous systems to
control rovers on the surface of mars in
the mid-2000s further drawing the
public's attention to the exciting
progress in robotics at the time the
2010s saw deep learning approaches
accelerate to new heights imagenet
launched the large-scale visual
recognition challenge to quantitatively
assess the ability of ai systems to
identify objects and images in 2011
ibm's watson beat jeopardy champion ken
jennings proving that ai systems could
understand and answer trivia questions
remarkably effectively then big tech
companies started rolling out virtual
assistants like apple's siri for the
iphone this helped people start to
become familiar with interacting with ai
technology then in 2012 two google
researchers jeff dean and andrew eng
trained a large neural network to
recognize images of cats despite giving
no background information by showing it
10 million unlabeled images from youtube
videos this was clear evidence that
neural networks were capable of learning
and it was all made possible by the
recent revolution in deep learning deep
learning models are deep in three
distinct ways first these deep networks
have more layers and each layer can
process a problem at a different level
of abstraction layers that are close to
the input layer handle low-level
concepts such as the edges in a picture
and as we move deeper into the network
we find more abstract concepts second
deep learning networks also have a
deeper pool of neurons to use to solve a
given problem a typical neural network
from 1990 might only have a hundred
neurons the human brain on the other
hand has about a hundred billion neurons
that meant that these old shallow
networks were limited but a
state-of-the-art neural network from
2016 could have over 1 million neurons
which is about the same number as a
bumblebee and based on current trends we
might see neural networks with the same
number of neurons as the human brain in
40 years but human brains aren't just
collections of neurons they also have
structure finally deep learning is deep
in the sense that the neurons themselves
have many more connections in a highly
connected neural network from the 1980s
each neuron might have 150 connections
with other neurons a state-of-the-art
neural network today might have as many
connections as there are in a cat's
brain so deep neural networks have more
layers of neurons more total neurons and
also better connected neurons this rapid
advancement in ai technology was getting
worrisome though and smart people
started to ask if this could backfire ai
still had plenty of skeptics after all
identifying cats and photos seemed
relatively trivial compared to solving
real artificial general intelligence but
elon musk stephen hawking and 3000
others were concerned enough to sign an
open letter banning the development and
use of autonomous weapons in 2015. ai
systems built using deep learning were
showing no signs of slowing down and it
was becoming clear that some of these
systems could replace human workers that
led jeff hinton the father of modern
deep learning to recommend that we stop
training radiologists in 2016 the job of
identifying cancer in medical images
seemed like an ideal task for a deep
learning system and he thought that ai
would quickly take over hinton's
prediction is still hotly debated in
medical and ai circles today the last
few years have seen remarkable ai
progress in competitive games in 2016
the team at deepmind built a deep
learning system called alphago and beat
the reigning champion lee sadal in a
best-of-five match not only was lee
stunned to lose to a computer but
announcers were shocked by some of the
unorthodox moves played by the ai moves
that were assumed to be errors in the
code turned out to be brilliant new
strategies that had never been tried
before after mastering classic games
like chess and go the ai researchers set
their sights on more modern computer
games openai built a system that could
play dota 2 and deepmind mastered
starcraft 2. 2017 saw ai researchers
gather at the asilomar conference on
beneficial ai to discuss how to avoid
the existential risk from artificial
intelligence ai was beginning to
outperform humans in all manner of
activities and it was clear that
researchers needed to think very
carefully about how these systems were
designed ai could now be used by anyone
with a simple computer to create
essentially whatever digital information
they wanted deep fakes could generate
lifelike video of human faces that could
fool casual viewers and openai's gpt-3
could write complete sentences about
anything on command and that brings us
to today open ai just released dolly 2 a
system for generating remarkable images
from simple text prompts and that's what
you've been seeing throughout this video
what a time to be alive if you want to
learn more about how ai is advancing the
self-driving car industry just watch
this video next thanks a lot